[Music]
to many both cryptocurrencies and
cockroaches are unwelcome pests
cockroaches infect your home and spread
disease and crypto is used for all kinds
of unsavory things criminals use it to
launder money terrorists use it to make
payments but both also appear to be
indestructible if you chop off a
cockroach's head it can live for up to a
week stepping on them or squishing them
is no guarantee either and the same
appears to be true for crypto in some
ways the industry's head has been
chopped off both Chang Pang Xiao and
bankman freed the founder of the world's
biggest and second biggest
cryptocurrency exchanges are now
awaiting sentencing for financial crimes
and Regulators are stepping on crypto as
well and yet Bitcoin ended 2023 higher
than it was at the start of the year so
why is crypto so hard to kill for one
indestructibility is built into the
underlying technology blockchains like
Bitcoin and ethereum can't go bankrupt
and be shut down they are databases of
transactions verified by a decentral
ized network of computers who were
incentivized by the promise of newly
created tokens so the only way the whole
architecture can collapse is if the
price of those tokens goes to zero and
there are lots of people who believe
that crypto is worth more than zero
crypto also has a long history of
seeming to out fox death the price
history of Bitcoin looks like a mountain
range with lots of Peaks rather than a
bubble with just a single Peak Bitcoin
can also have uses in an Investment
Portfolio and it's poised to potentially
become a more popular choice for the
first time you can invest in Bitcoin
ETFs after the SEC gave the green light
to a select few funds Bitcoin seems to
have established itself as a legitimate
financial asset able to bounce back when
you least expect
it I'm Matthew favas Finance
correspondent at The Economist to read
more for coverage on bitcoin please
click on the link and thank you for
[Music]
watching